I'm Helen Pearson and this is me in the
morning
I'm a features editor for nature and I
find myself pretty busy all the time
that's why when I heard about a unique
lab in Oxford that uses Diaries to learn
about how people use time I became
really interested they gave me the
chance to complete one of their Diaries
I wore a small camera which took three
photos a minute through my whole day and
an accelerometer to wear around my wrist
which tracked my activity this is my
commute to work it was a day when I had
to take my two older children to school
and then drop my toddler at the nursery
before heading to work time you studies
and accelerometers are a good way of
finding out when people are actually
most active it turns out that a session
at the gym or exercise class tends to
burn up less energy than things like
domestic work or childcare because
although these things are less
physically intense we tend to do them
for longer I was most active during my
commute and also in the mornings and
evenings when I was with the kids and
doing things around the house
my days at work mostly involves sitting
at the computer dealing with new stories
and endless emails as well as going to
meetings it usually feels really busy
some of the researchers have looked at
this idea that we're all much busier
these days than we were in the past but
despite a general perception that we're
all busier time east irie suggests that
on average that's not true there are
some exceptions though two notable
examples are single parents who work and
professionals with young children who
were under pressure to work hard and
spend quality time with their kids
researchers suggest that one reason for
this perception that everyone is busier
now is that business has become a type
of status symbol we say we're busy
because it makes us look good
whereas saying you've got nothing on and
are watching TV doesn't sound so great a
lot of people tend to overestimate how
long they spend working - some
professions are particularly bad at this
like police and teachers and lawyers
they overestimate the most so now I've
escaped meetings and I'm on my way back
home one thing I learned from looking at
all my photos was how much I use my
phone checking emails on the web and
listening to music it seems like it was
hardly out of my hand
my train was delayed on this day so I
ended up answering emails reading nature
and science and then doing a bit more
work another thing I was asked to do in
the diary was to record how much I was
enjoying each activity I was pretty
unhappy about being stuck on the train
while my happiest moments seemed to be
when I was sleeping walking through the
park and putting my toddler to bed when
I got home I did a few more chores and
helped put the children to bed but in
fact my partner Peter was doing most of
the childcare and domestic work that
evening that fits really well with what
the Oxford lab has found compared with
the 1960s women now tend to spend less
time doing unpaid work like household
chores and more time in paid work it
also seems that men are gradually doing
more domestic work as attitudes are
changing so let's break down my day over
a 24-hour period I spent most of my day
working more than nine hours but this
was the day nature's stories go to press
so I wasn't surprised it was that busy
the next biggest slice was sleeping and
what the researchers called personal
care which means showering cleaning your
teeth and so on
then I spent 3 hours 20 minutes on
household work and family which was more
than I thought it would be and it also
showed how much of my day was eaten up
by commuting that was around two and a
half hours even though I lived this day
looking at the data was still really
revealing and time use researchers have
already collected about 150 Diaries like
mine to see what more they can learn
about how people use their time so if
you want to know where your time is
going I'd really recommend keeping a
Tiny's diary for a day